this program is brought to you by Emory
University hello my name is Carrie
peluso I'm associate vice president for
research administration here at Emory my
experience with tobacco is that I've
lived with a smoker for most of my life
my husband of over 25 years it was a
smoker until 10 months ago at age 42 he
almost died when one of his main
arteries they called the Widowmaker was
ninety-five percent clogged he left the
hospital with a stent a bag full of
pills and lots of emotions to deal with
last spring he was against him by the
doctors and diagnosed with weak arteries
they said that he had the arteries of a
man about 20 years older than he was ten
to twelve years ago he was experiencing
very bad back pain and was diagnosed
with degenerative disc disease what we
didn't understand at that point was that
the degeneration had been excelled by
the smoking and will continue to be
accelerated by his smoking in the past
year he's had two surgeries related to
his degenerative disc disease he's went
through the recoveries related to them
and he did quit smoking the night before
a surgical cervical fusion surgery was
the last time he smoked we still live
with the threat of his smoking though
because much of the damage that he did
was not reversible and we don't know
when and how it will impact our future I
fully support programs that help people
realize the dangers of smoking the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University